is there advice you can give to people
to young to young kids that are living
through a shitty situation of any sort a
tough life find a thing you like
try to find a thing that you really
enjoy try to find a thing that you're
passionate about like an activity yes
for me early on it was drawing it was uh
illustrations it was uh comic books i
wanted to be a comic book illustrator
and then it went from uh comic book
drawing and illustrations to um martial
arts
so but it was just another thing that i
was very very passionate about
and
that
was my vehicle out of my dilemma that
was my vehicle out of my my own anxiety
and trauma and my own issues and
insecurities and
find something find a thing that you
genuinely enjoy because getting good at
things you genuinely enjoy
is extremely beneficial for young people
because it lets you know that
like everybody thinks they're a loser
every young person thinks they're a
loser at least a young person in the
situation i was at like i didn't know i
wasn't a loser until i started winning
until i started doing martial arts
martial arts taught me that like i could
get better at stuff that it wasn't i
wasn't really a loser i just was someone
who was like in a [ __ ] up situation
but you could channel all that energy
that you have as a young person into
something and get better at it and then
all sudden people admired me i was like
this is crazy so i went from being
someone who
was incredibly insecure
and basically a failure
to someone who was really successful at
this one thing that was very dangerous
that other people were scared of
and that gave me immense confidence and
also a real understanding
of the direct correlation between hard
work and success
and uh kind of understanding that you're
not a loser right that there is some
a diamond in the rough yeah and also an
understanding that you can't listen to
people because even my parents didn't
want me to do martial arts they didn't
want me to fight they didn't want me to
do stand-up there's like you have to
understand like who you are
and then in the face of other people's
either criticism
or
you know
lack of
faith in your ability to succeed
you push through and there's great
benefit in that and then you realize
that you can kind of apply that to other
things in life you can apply that to
critics you can apply that to social
media commentators you can apply that to
a lot of things
okay what about
uh young people in their 50s
can you give advice to like imagine
you're sitting you're sitting back
probably still here in texas in your 90s
looking back what advice would that guy
give to you today
or like people
you know people that have done some [ __ ]
in their 50s you've gone through a hell
of a life
there's potentially some incentive to
settle down
you've got a great family to relax
but maybe there's some incentive to
still do epic [ __ ]
still be david goggins running in the
middle of the desert
[ __ ] into a camera if you're david
goggins you have to be david goggins
i don't think there's a path for that
guy that exists at this stage of his
life other than that do you think he'll
be 70 and still screaming yes okay a
hundred percent
100 if if david and i are alive
we're both 70 he's gonna call me up and
say stay hard [ __ ]
guaranteed guaranteed so lean into
whatever the [ __ ] you are at this point
well if you're enjoying it but if you're
not enjoying it rethink your life try to
figure out why you why you're not
enjoying it you still think it's
possible to shift things in your 50s
yeah if you're alive you can get better
yeah what yeah no matter what if you're
alive you can shift things i mean if
you're 90 years old and you know you
have a month to live you could apologize
for the things you think you did wrong
and maybe
sort of reconcile and and shape
relationships you have with the people
that around you better so that they they
feel differently about you after you're
gone
yeah i always love people in their 70s
who are like like getting back into
dating or something like that yeah
i was watching a video about a woman
who's in her 60s who just started
powerlifting
nice
yeah and same with you just so you see
people get into jiu-jitsu
a white belt that's like 70. yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot of if you're
alive
you can get better at stuff
and
i don't think people are happy if they
don't have
puzzles and complex tasks and things
that are interesting to them whether
it's an art project or whether it's uh
learning something completely new like
stand-up comedy like
doing things that are difficult is
it it's as much of a nourishment of the
mind
as uh food is a nourishment of the body
i think you need things
that that are puzzling to you where you
have to
find your own human potential in the
difficulty of the task
and and work your way through things at
least for me
for me i mean i can only speak for me
because i'm the only i'm the only life
that i've ever lived that i'm aware of
and in my life that has been a 100
constant
i i am a very happy person and i have
never had a moment where i'm not doing
difficult [ __ ] yeah ever
uh what matters most is how well you
walk through the fires you just keep
starting fighters for yourself to walk
through well they don't necessarily have
to be fires
right because fires are like kind of out
of control lukewarm uh tasks the
surfaces tasks give yourself something
an arduous
difficult
task where you're challenged
challenged mentally and challenged
physically one of the great things about
being challenged physically is it's also
mental the people that don't understand
that have never really been challenged
physically people that think that
physical challenges are just like
just physical it's just
brute grunt work it's not it's emotional
intelligence it's understanding your
desire to quit
and you know conquering your inner [ __ ]
all that stuff is
it's mental it's playing out inside your
head and there's a mental strength that
you acquire from that that you can apply
to intellectual pursuits and the the
people that don't think that or the
people that haven't attempted them and
there's an arrogance to people that
only pursue intellectual exercises only
pursue intellectual things and don't
pursue anything physical that the
physical stuff is based it's grunt work
it's primal it's not necessary i don't
think that's accurate i don't think that
they're i mean obviously there's people
like stephen hawkings who have no
opportunity to do anything physical
right
his physical dilemma is keeping us or
was keeping his heart beating
but for most people i think you can
really benefit from physical struggle
and you benefit from it in a mental way
and i think that is overlooked that's
unfortunately overlooked by academics
and intellectuals who
they make excuses for why they're fat
and lazy or scrawny well they don't need
to be
it's not even about the fat or all that
it's like literally there's something
about the physical challenge that's
really good for you especially if you're
academic especially if you do
intellectual type stuff there's this
great roboticist at mit russ tedrick he
runs barefoot
to and from mit every day i love it um
like seven seven to ten miles each way
barefoot barefoot well he's uh he
studies legged locomotion legged robots
so for him it's also interesting
how the human body moves he sees the
beauty and all of in all movement what
do his feet look like
you know calloused destroyed right no
just calloused they're nice they're they
form a nice
it's not like i gave them a foot massage
but but i mean they they look uh
and i don't have a foot fetish so i
don't uh i'm not able to correctly
invest
evaluate another man's feet i apologize
for this but uh they don't look [ __ ]
up does he run on concrete yeah he runs
all surfaces
and he does everything completely
barefoot
uh the running part at work
so one of the things he has to do is fit
into society which means he has to
change clothes and appear normal right
so does he wear like uh zero shoes you
know those no he's not type shoes no
because that's like very
happy wokey type of thing
no like he doesn't he's barefoot when
he's running and then he wears like
normal
looking stuff like dressing she's
working his way up to running barefoot
uh so he was significantly overweight
and his advisor
uh this this this other uh famous person
at mit who was a roboticist took his own
life
and that made him uh that made rust face
his own mortality
i think i mean the you start to ask big
questions about your well-being like
holy [ __ ] this ride can end at any
moment and so he started taking his
sort of physical well-being seriously
but as a result of that not did he did
he become like shredded
but he's also
discovered the intellectual value
uh the humbling value of physical
exercise
he's not preachy about it all i don't
think i actually rarely hear him
advise it to anyone he just does it as a
as a almost like meditation or something
like that it's it's definitely a form of
meditation and you can attest to that
right you do quite a bit of running
there's a thing about a
it you kind of almost like a mantra gets
formed and you you get into it it was
great here in the austin heat 100 degree
weather
that tests you you know what i love to
do outside pull sleds
that's my thing
i love to pull sleds outside in the heat
yeah i did today yeah i love it
you